so you did this report what did you find
out about the various some well avenues
of making money in that cannabis
business
well basically on the whole it looks
like that it could be an eleven billion
dollar industry by 2019 this is by
investment and research firm ArcView
market research which actually focuses
specifically on the cannabis industry
now in terms of the growth areas of
Radian market research said that
cultivation is one aspect as you might
expect which is a big moneymaker which
accounts for about maybe twenty percent
twenty five percent or so of the whole
entire industry in addition to that
there's also biotechnology which is
looking at fertilizers and things to
basically make cannabis go faster better
grow purer in addition there's also
things like software and like security
that comprise the whole entire sector
and the stocks of companies that are
linked in some way to cannabis and
marijuana they are available for trading
but they don't actually are direct
they're not directly related are they
some are some aren't again with this of
Radian capital research last year they
have this some interesting index the
cannabis index and it rose by about
thirty eight percent in 2014 and looking
ahead it looks like that it might rise
again later this year but we're only
halfway through and based on the numbers
for the you know estimates coming out
over the next few years it could be a
rise of about five billion dollars or so
all right well let's talk about some of
the obstacles that exist and some of the
people solving some of these problems I
want to introduce Olivia Mannix Olivia
Maddox is the co-founder of a Cantabria
which describes itself as the first
cannabis marketing agency
Olivia joins us from Denver Olivia what
if you could just describe what are some
of the particular obstacles or
challenges that you face in this
burgeoning new industry thank you so
much for having me this evening some
challenges we have are the laws and
regulations within advertising and
marketing within the public sector so
are they similar to the rules and
restrictions that govern alcohol and
tobacco advertising yes they are very
similar
except for in the marijuana industry we
cannot have advertisements on television
and our there's some hurdles that you
need to pass in order to let's say
advertise in various publications they
have to find out how many people that a
subscribe would be let's say over the
age of 21 yes so 70% of the audience
must be over the age of 21 in order to
advertise in that channel yes now Olivia
advertising actually isn't just about
throwing a marijuana sign on anymore and
having the leaf there isn't it it's it's
evolving to something that's trying to
include the mainstream to tell us more
about that right yes as canna brand is
the first marijuana ad agency we have
lots of strategy and creation behind all
of our campaigns so pulling through just
different segments and such Olivia I
wonder if you can describe who are your
clients so one of my clients is Neos
they are vape pen company they are out
of Denver Colorado and they since we
have trouble with advertising on a
national scale of them what we do is
licensing so we build the brands and
other states right now they're looking
at working in California or have
launched Oregon and Nevada apparently
and Washington and Washington DC or
watch time Washington say that beg your
pardon
say